New tonight,
a threatening note
and a white powder substance
sent to the office of Manhattan D.A.
Alvin Bragg.
This after multiple threats,
including bomb
threats were made against the court.
And just a day after Trump
posted this since deleted image
that shows him
appearing to take a bat to Bragg
and warning
that if he is indicted over
the hush money
payment to Stormy Daniels quote,
potential death and destruction
and such a false charge
could be catastrophic for our country.
Cara Scannell is OUTFRONT.
Cara.
More than reminiscent, of course,
of what he said and tweeted
before January six.
What else do you know
about the threat today to the D.A.
and his office?
Well, Erin, sources
tell us that a 911
call came in around noon,
that the DA's office had received
a suspicious package
containing a white sort of
white powdery substance
and a threatening letter to Bragg
We're told that from the DA's office
that this was
then transported to the NYPD
and the city's Department
of Environmental Protection.
They review the substance and determine
that it was non-hazardous.
It's now at the EPA's lab.
And NYPD says the investigation to
this is continuing.
And as you say,
this is part of a real kind of stepped up
rhetoric by Trump,
really beginning last week
when he was calling for protests, saying
he was going to be arrested and charged.
Of course,
he wasn't arrested and charged,
but that didn't change the calculus.
You know,
there have been, as you say, bomb threats
that are non-credible
that were called in.
There are bomb sweeps
at the courthouses daily
and that there is just
a general increased
sense of security,
you know,
whether it's for protests or for
perhaps something even like this.
But we've seen
I've been down on the ground all week.
We saw an increase in NYPD personnel,
increase in court security officers.
You know,
just showing a little bit more vigilance
around the area,
you know,
particularly as Trump
is raising the rhetoric
on all these threats.
And of course, the grand jury meets again
on Monday
where this investigation
into Trump's role in the hush money
will continue Erin.
All right, Kara, thank you very much.
Ryan Goodman is with me
tonight along with Karen.
Agnes, Filo, former chief assistant D.A.
for then Manhattan D.A.
Cy Vance.
So, of course,
I know you worked on this as well,
criminal defense attorney now.
So you did used to work at this office.
So when you hear this today
in the context of these Twitter threats
and everything else that's happening.
How old are you?
Well, he has committed new crimes.
These are absolutely criminal behavior.
On his part with the posting,
the baseball bat
image to hit to album Greg's head,
calling him an animal and then calling
for death and destruction
because it's just like January six.
He knows what his words mean.
He wasn't calling for peaceful protests.
This is a call to action
to his supporters.
And he has stepped over the line
and committed multiple,
albeit misdemeanors at this point.
But he has committed multiple crimes.
We'll see if he gets charged with them.
But he has absolutely crossed a line.
All right.
Does that impact the indictment here?
I mean
I mean, I
guess I mean, Brian,
I guess I'm saying is,
you know, you've got
these are human beings involved, right?
A day as a human being. Right.
And he's going to obviously,
he's trying to do
what he thinks he can actually prosecute.
But when you have someone
making these threats
and things like this happen,
obviously it gets emotionally charged
I don't think it'll affect
whether or not he decides to indict.
I think in
some sense,
that decision has probably been made
long before these threats began
one way or the other.
And so I think he'd line it up.
But I do agree with Karen that I do now
think he has to consider.
Does he add to the indictment
or additional charges?
Because he also would, by that way, send
a signal
that this has to stop
and you're also concerned
about whether there could be a gag order,
which would just
be incredibly complicated
because talking about someone
who is running for president,
who's out there every day talking.
That's right.
So a very good close
example is Roger Stone,
when he was undergoing a trial
and he put the picture in Instagram
up of the judge and crosshairs.
And that had crossed a line
so that the judge said
we had a kind of a gag order,
but now we're going to impose
a full gag order.
You may not use social media
to talk about this case.
So given what Trump is doing,
if you are currently under indictment,
I could imagine
this would be the next question.
The next day at a hearing
before that judge
and this looks and this is the direction
it might go.
But then, as you
say, it's
such an unusual circumstance
it's not just that First Amendment,
free speech rights are on the other side
of the equation.
It's political speech
by a political candidate
for the highest office in the country
that's heavily
weighed on the other side
of the equation.
So, you know, here
we are on a Friday night, a week ago
on a Friday night,
we thought this could be happening.
Right, or happened on Monday.
Is it is it
is it still imminent
in terms of an announcement
if there is an indictment
or if there is not an indictment,
which I know is unexpected
but could be the case,
is that still something
that could happen any day?
I think it's going to happen Monday
or Wednesday. Of next week.
I think law enforcement
is currently having
discussions about security and how
and when would be the safest
and most convenient
time for him to surrender
And I think based on that date will be
then what day do they decide to go in
and ask the grand jury to take a vote?
Because too much time in between.
You see what Trump is already doing
he's already
causing his supporters
to make death threats.
He said himself,
making death threats and white powder,
all the things you're seeing,
the bomb scare.
So law enforcement
is going to want to keep everybody safe.
And so they're going to wait to see
and try to coordinate
those two things
as close to each other as possible.
And so, Ryan,
this comes on the heels of a legal blow
today for Trump in another probe,
special counsel,
so that a judge
there ruled
that a former
former top
aides are not protected
by executive privilege
so that they're going to have to come in
and speak.
That includes Mark Meadows,
who would have to appear before
that grand jury. Right.
In the special counsel
probe in Washington.
So you know, Mark Meadows,
as we know, is
central to everything, right?
He was chief of staff.
He was on the call
with Brad Raffensperger,
texted with a lot of GOP officials
on the day of January six.
And that's just what we know. Right.
I mean, the whole point
that Mark Meadows is what we
what we don't know.
So how significant
is this ruling on executive privilege?
I think it's hugely significant,
especially because the court of appeals,
if Trump decides to try to appeal,
will probably just slap it down.
We know this has happened already before.
And as CNN has reported, for example,
the former White House,
the White House counsel
and the deputy White House counsel
also tried to do executive privilege,
but then they testified.
Mark Meadows,
like you say, is central,
one of the former
January six staff committee members,
so that he was our MVP
Without him,
we wouldn't have had the playbook.
And that's
because he partially cooperated
with them.
This is about full cooperation
under threat with the Justice Department.
And I think he can reveal
so many things across
the gamut of issues.
Has his path to stopping it run out?
I mean, this is that he now has to.
It seems like it seems like it. Yeah.
Smith seems to be able to get
who he needs into the grand jury
very quickly.
All right.
Well, we shall see,
because this is one of them
waiting and waiting.
And I think everyone stopped
even holding their breath.
All right. Thank you both so very much.